nach dem gipfel ist vor der feinarbeit
um das blutvergießen in libyen zu
stoppen prüft die eu unter anderem ein
comeback der mission so viel anvertraut
vergewaltigte manipuliert wegen des
verdachts auf hundertfachen
kindesmissbrauch steht ein
pfadfinderleiter aus staufen vor gericht
und 56 minuten topform schnell und
sicher zieht julia görges in die zweite
runde der australian open ein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport an land formiert
die reaktionen auf die berliner
libyenkonferenz sind überwiegend positiv
heute ging es bei den eu-außenministern
in brüssel schon darum wie sich europa
an den friedensbemühungen in dem
bürgerkriegsland beteiligen kann
dazu gleich mehr zunächst fast david
sauer die wichtigsten vereinbarungen
zwischen den 16 staaten und
organisationen zusammen
zuerst muss die waffenruhe halten da
waren alle gipfelteilnehmer einig
milizen beider seiten sollen entwaffnet
und aufgelöst werden
die staaten verpflichten sich keine
waffen mehr zu liefern keine einmischung
in innere angelegenheiten libyens sonst
drohen un sanktionen die
konfliktparteien werden aufgerufen die
menschenrechte zu wahren
keine außergerichtlichen hinrichtungen
keine sexuelle gewalt und keine folter
mehr anzuwenden
die öleinnahmen sollen allen menschen im
land zugute kommen
transparent und gerecht verteilt unter
führung der vereinten nationen soll das
staatliche gewaltmonopol wieder
hergestellt werden und libyen so
wörtlich zum politischen prozess
zurückkehren
perspektivisch könnte es dann freie
faire und glaubwürdige parlaments und
präsidentschaftswahlen geben
insgesamt 55 punkte umfasst die
vereinbarung und viele fragen sind noch
offen zum beispiel wer überwacht dass
tatsächlich keine waffen mehr nach
libyen geliefert werden ein vorschlag
aus brüssel ist den mittelmeerraum vor
der küste libyens wieder stärker zu
kontrollieren
vom treffen der eu-außenminister
berichtet gunnar krüger
die deutsche diplomatie bringt auf
berlin erfolge mit immerhin so groß dass
ihr chef in brüssel bremsen muss im
moment findet eine debatte statt den
zweiten schritt vor dem ersten zu machen
wir brauchen erst einmal einen
waffenstillstand die man sichern kann
und kontrollieren kann bevor man die
maßnahmen beschließt die zur sicherung
dann geeignet werden europa wäre dafür
bislang keine große hilfe
je nachdem wer von wem öl bezieht
standen einzelne mitglieder zu
ministerpräsident ice age andere zum
abtrünnigen general haffter nun aber
solle in libyen die eu helfen der
außenbeauftragte will eine bewaffnete
missionen der judoka eine waffenruhe
will muss sie auch überwachen die
vereinten nationen die afrikanische
union die europäische union einer muss
es machen
forward hast du doch nicht mal ein
waffenembargo kann die eu bislang
durchsetzen sofia die marine mission zu
diesem zweck rettete auch flüchtlinge im
streit mit italiens innenminister um
deren aufnahme wurde sie 2009 10
ausgesetzt
das ist zusammengebrochen damals unser
salvini zu wenig wir müssen so viel will
aufbaut
reilly ist nachfolger im amt ist milder
im ton aber hart in der sache 4 war
sofia muss auseinandergenommen und ganz
anders zusammengesetzt werden es muss
eine mission sein um die einfuhr von
waffen nach libyen zu verhindern
eine mission um das embargo zu
überwachen und sonst nichts
doch auch der außenbeauftragte will dass
sophia flüchtlinge aus seenot retten in
der sitzung habe er keinen widerspruch
gehört danach klang das anders aus
brüssel und berlin sind unsere
korrespondenten zugeschaltet beginnen
wir mit anne gellinek in brüssel
so viel ist schon einmal gescheitert
warum sollte das jetzt besser klappen
auf den ersten blick sind die
voraussetzungen für eine eu mission im
mittelmeer jetzt günstiger es gibt eine
neue italienische regierung die durchaus
schiffe mit flüchtlingen wieder in ihre
häfen lässt und es gibt eine neue
entschlossenheit seitens der eu diesen
prozess der durch die libyen konferenz
von berlin angestoßen wurde jetzt zu
unterstützen aber auch die alten
probleme die sofia hatte sind alle noch
da denn sobald europäische kriegsschiffe
im mittelmeer kreuzen um das um ein
mögliches waffenembargo gegen libyen zu
überwachen
werden sie unweigerlich auf boote mit
flüchtlingen stoßen die sie dann
verpflichtet sind zu retten und damit
stösst europa gleich wieder auf das
größte schwelendes problem das es hat
nämlich die ungelöste flüchtlings
verteilung die nach wie vor keine lösung
hat und die letztlich auch die letzte
sofia mission lahmlegte also trotz aller
demonstrativen entschlossenheit der eu
außenminister heute hier gibt es wenig
hinweise dass eine neue sofia mission
besser funktionieren könnte als die alte
die frage ist auch welchen beitrag
deutschland leistet theo koll in berlin
ist die bundesregierung bereit
bundeswehrsoldaten nach libyen zu
schicken
nun erst einmal hat die bundesregierung
heute versucht tempo aus der debatte zu
nehmen ein deutscher einsatz sagten sie
sei zunächst einmal ja abhängig von den
bedingungen in libyen also
beispielsweise von einem
waffenstillstand aber allen beteiligten
hier in berlin ist klar dass die im
libyen-konflikt jetzt übernommene
politische führung ist viel schwieriger
machen wird sich am ende wenn nötig
nicht auch vor ort zu beteiligen
beispielsweise um einen waffenstillstand
dann auch zu überwachen
die verteidigungsministerin hat sich ja
schon am wochenende offen gezeigt für
eine beteiligung der bundeswehr grüne
und fdp sind ebenfalls gesprächsbereit
die linke hingegen lehnt einen einsatz
weiterhin strikt ab insgesamt
aber gilt in berlin das bewusstsein dass
deutschland mehr verantwortung in der
welt übernehmen zu müssen ist spürbar
gestiegen im fall von libyen hat die
bundesregierung das jetzt politisch
bewiesen und es wäre jetzt auch nicht
völlig überraschend wenn daraus dann
auch weitere schritte folgen
die einschätzungen aus berlin und
brüssel vielen dank theo koll und anne
gellinek schwierig die lage auch im
libanon der regierungskritischen
proteste sind dort wieder aufgeflammt am
wochenende wurden dabei etwa 500
menschen verletzt
gestern versuchten demonstranten in
beirut in das parlamentsgebäude
einzudringen
sicherheitskräfte trieben sie mit
gummigeschossen und wasserwerfern zurück
seit monaten gibt es im libanon protest
der wegen korruption und misswirtschaft
ministerpräsident hariri musste
zurücktreten
die bildung einer neuen regierung kommt
aber nicht voran
die kluft zwischen arm und reich wird
immer größer das zeigen neue zahlen der
hilfsorganisation oxfam und auch die
ungleichheit zwischen männern und frauen
ist groß weltweit leisten mädchen und
frauen pro tag 12,5 milliarden stunden
unbezahlte arbeit im haushalt bei der
kinderbetreuung und der pflege von
angehörigen geschätzt entspricht das
einem gegenwert von rund 11 millionen
dollar pro jahr
angesichts dieser zahlen fordert oxfam
dass frauen stärker an den erträgen des
wirtschaftslebens beteiligt werden
müssten wie wahnsinnig schwer es für
kinder ist sich gegen sexuellen
missbrauch zu wehren zeigt ein fall aus
staufen dort soll ein betreuer von
pfadfindern hundertfach vier jungen
missbraucht haben
jahrelang bis endlich einer der
betroffenen das ihm vom täter auferlegte
schweigegelübde brach und sich seiner
mutter anvertraute
heute begann in freiburg der prozess
zusammen von lojewski
sein gesicht hatte er unter einem
pullover verborgen seine mutmaßlichen
taten aber kommen jetzt ans licht
hundertfachen missbrauch von mindestens
vier jungen im alter zwischen 7 und 14
jahren
das alles unter dem dach der
christlichen pfadfinder deutschlands
es geschah hier in staufen bei freiburg
auf 400 euro basis leitete christian l
eine fahrt kindergruppe schon 2010 soll
er einen achtjährigen missbraucht haben
doch erst acht jahre später findet der
junge die kraft sich seinen eltern zu
offenbaren das ist eine ganz große
schwierigkeit weil da der der dom
credito kritiker sehr groß ist die jungs
haben das gefühl sie gehören mit dazu zu
dem system sie wirkten mit und deswegen
ist es sehr schade behaftet sich hier zu
offenbaren
christian l war bereits einmal
verurteilt wegen sexueller gewalt gegen
kinder
er ging in berufung und kam wieder frei
zwar glaubte man den betroffenen der
vorfall war aber nicht mehr nachweisbar
so entschieden die richter im zweifel
für den angeklagten und die pfadfinder
stellten ihn wieder ein aus meiner sicht
hätte man zumindest aus dem ersten
strafverfahren im jahr 2004 bis 2007 die
schlüsse folgern müssen dass der
angeklagte nicht mehr beschäftigt werden
darf und sich zumindest die kirche über
den ausgang des verfahrens intensiver
hätte erkundigen müssen das aber
passierte nicht bei den pfadfindern will
man jetzt aus den fehlern der
vergangenheit gelernt haben
wir müssen uns aktiv dafür einsetzen
dass kinder und jugendliche wissen an
wen sie sich wenden können wir müssen
speziell geschulte ansprechpartner und
die strukturen schaffen so dass es uns
möglich ist darüber ein klima zu
schaffen des hinschauens aufnahme
achtens für die betroffenen kommt das zu
spät sie leiden bis heute in die schule
zu gehen für manche unmöglich vor
gericht müssen sie dennoch erneut
aussagen und so dass er lebte wieder
durch leiden zum münchner landgericht
und einem bizarren fall ein mann gibt
sich als arzt aus und verspricht frauen
in internet-chats geld wenn sie sich
selbst lebensgefährliche stromstöße
zufügen für medizinische studien wie er
sagt heute das urteil gegen den
30-jährigen elf jahre haft wegen
versuchten mordes in 13 fällen
der mann hatte seine bis zu 120 opfer
unter anderem dazu überredet einfache
apparaturen zu basteln und damit strom
an den schläfen anzulegen
laut gericht aus sexuellen motiven alle
opfer haben die torturen überlebt
falsch geparkt ein knöllchen an der
windschutzscheibe für städte sind das
erhebliche einnahmen in frankfurt am
main verhängen auch private
dienstleister solche verfahren gelder
und zwar massenweise und im namen der
stadt
das darf aber nicht sein entschied heute
das zuständige oberlandesgericht und
erklärte hunderttausende dieser
verwarnungen für ungültig linken klinge
mit mir
die stadtpolizei darf knöllchen
schreiben so wie hier in frankfurt gibt
es aber seit einigen jahren auch
leiharbeiter von privaten dienstleistern
die strafzettel an falschparker
verteilen
diese art der verkehrsüberwachung sei
allerdings gesetzeswidrig erklärte heute
das oberlandesgericht in frankfurt am
main
der beschluss beruht eigentlich auf dem
staatlichen gewaltmonopol wenn der staat
regeln erlässt an die man sich halten
muss dann muss auch selbst regeln dass
diese verschiedenen verstöße durch seine
eigenen bedienstete dann geahndet werden
er darf sich da nicht dritter bedienen
ein betroffener aus dem jahr 2017 hatte
geklagt und recht bekommen
allein 2008 10 gab es nach angaben des
gerichts mehr als 700.000 park verstöße
in frankfurt die summe der bußgelder
mehr als zehn millionen euro
die aktuelle entscheidung des gerichts
ist auch für andere städte relevant die
entscheidung gilt zwar nicht
deutschlandweit aber es können auch
falschparker in anderen städten und
anderen bundesländern betroffen sein
das heißt wer interesse hat einfach mal
bei der stadt von der in kirchen
bekommen hat nachfragen
das lohnt sich aber wohl nur für
aktuelle strafzettel bußgelder die
bereits gezahlt wurden sind behalten
ihre gültigkeit hier hätte bürger leider
keine möglichkeit das geld
zurückzufordern
die stadt frankfurt hat sich bislang
noch nicht geäußert wie sie mit den zu
unrecht ausgestellten strafzettel
umgehen will
unser nächstes thema macht den chinesen
zunehmend sorgen es geht um eine neue
atemwegserkrankungen die durch viren
verursacht wird und nicht ungefährlich
ist
mehr als 200 fälle sind inzwischen
bekannt drei verliefen tödlich
hier in deutschland sehen experten
keinen grund zur panik die chinesische
regierung indes ist alarmiert stefanie
schöneborn und ulf röller berichten aus
china heute abend in woran vor dem
zentralen krankenhaus die sorge über das
krone virus ist sichtbar
die meisten infizierten patienten liegen
in diesem krankenhaus in zentralchina
die lage ist ziemlich ernst das kann man
daran erkennen dass hier ein wagen
vorgefahren ist der die ganze 1 fata
desinfiziert die menschen und die ärzte
und die verantwortlichen sind eben sehr
besorgt weil die zahl der infizierten so
dramatisch schnell angestiegen ist
das chinesische staatsfernsehen erfolgt
den strengen regeln der kommunistischen
partei informiert und waren die
bevölkerung wie es hier selten vorkommt
den aktuellen daten zufolge handelt ist
es bei der neuen art der korona virus
lungenentzündung definitiv um eine
übertragung von mensch zu mensch
in london gab es zwei fälle die person
war nicht in wo haben aber ihre
familienmitglieder sie haben das virus
weiter gegeben
das virus gehört zu der familie der
korona viren zu der auch der tödliche
saß erzählt viele trauen den zahlen der
chinesischen regierung nicht glauben es
gibt mehr infizierte einzelne fälle gibt
es mittlerweile auch außerhalb chinas in
thailand japan und südkorea
es gibt eine inkubationszeit von etwa
zwei wochen
und in dieser zeit wenn die patienten
reisen können sie dass wir uns natürlich
mitnehmen in andere stellen
das ist dort geschehen aber ich möchte
noch mal betonen dass es eben sehr
wenige fälle sind außerhalb chinas
bislang
viele sind besorgt in china da vor allem
jetzt die große reisewelle rund um das
chinesische neujahrsfest beginnt die
angst vor mögliche ansteckung mit dem
neuen virus reist dieses jahr mit der
schauspieler kabarettist und musiker
joseph hannesschläger ist tot er starb
mit 57 jahren an krebs
den meisten war bekannt als ermittler in
der zdf krimiserie rosenheim cops 17
jahre lang über führte er ein mörder als
bayerische ermittler unter blühen hofe
bodenständig mit schwächen
augenzwinkernd bayerische vitamine fast
gemütlich aber vergnüglich brachte ihr
täter zur strecke von der echten polizei
wurden er und seine kollegen zu ehren
kommissaren befördert ritterschlag für
einen fernseh polizisten
jetzt sind wir beim tennis norbert rolle
hier ist der runde beide in australia
und trat julia goerges souverän ihr
spiel gewonnen in nur 56 minuten bezwang
die slowakin viktoria como va
probleme wegen der buschfeuer gab es
heute nicht aber das thema beschäftigt
die profis asse für australien julia
görges schlägt sie sowieso gerne
diesmal sind sie doppelt schön die
deutsche spendet bei jedem unerreichten
aufschlag umgerechnet 60 euro für die
opfer der verheerenden buschfeuer heute
sind es allein neun asse also 540 euro
ja ich gebe mir mühe auf jeden fall dass
ich einen guten zweck alle zusammen zu
bekommen auch im doppel mit der erspart
ihr zusammen schauen wir mal wo am ende
herauskommen ihr erstrundenmatch gegen
die slowakin cosmo war ist insgesamt
kurz und bündig der klare sieg mit 6 1
und 6 2
damit kann die nummer 39 der welt in
runde zwei gegen die kroatin marge
weiter jagd auch doppelt wertvolle asse
machen
auch philipp kohlschreiber ist weiter
jan lennard struff aber musste sich in
runde eins mit der nummer 2 der tennis
welt messen
nur war djokovic und schied nach großem
kampf gegen den titelverteidiger aus
serbien aus jürgen klopp und der fc
liverpool sind in der premier league
einfach
aufzuhalten nach dem 2 0 erfolg gegen
manchester united sind die reds nur mit
16 punkten vorsprung tabellenführer der
neunzehnter heimsieg nacheinander
jugendclubs laune einfach prächtig die
fans singen bereits von titel natürlich
dürfen sie träumen und singen was sie
wollen solange sie ihren job machen in
dem moment in dem wir spielen alles gut
aber noch machen wir bei dieser party
nicht die party gestern beginnt mit der
führung durch abwehrchef merger van dyk
liverpool gegen den erz rivalen über 90
minuten dominant und so richtig zweifelt
kaum noch einer am ersten meistertitel
seit 30 jahren auch dank der
regelmäßigen topleistungen von topstar
sala in der nachspielzeit sein 20
der 150 sieg für jürgen klopp mit
liverpool
das war mir auch eine art von motivation
noch eine umarmung zum schluss wir sind
noch beim wetter morgen wird fast
überall sonnig nur an den küsten bleibt
es trüb die details hat gleich gunther
tiersch marietta slomka begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal wir
danken für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen schönen abend und bis morgen wenn
sie mir auch wieder sehen
[Musik]
einige zuschauer auf uns lastet ein
extrem hoher luftdruck von fast 1000 50
hektopascal normalerweise scheint die
sonne bei so einem hohen luftdruck das
ist in norddeutschland nicht der fall da
kommt immer wieder von der nordsee
feuchte luft wolken die sich darüber
lägen auch morgen zumindest an der küste
wird es wolkig sonst auch in
norddeutschland mehr und mehr
sonnenschein dabei ja heute nacht haben
wir meist in klaren himmel dazu
nebelfelder
an den flüssen und an den seen im süden
im norden bleibt es bewölkt dabei ist es
auch frostfrei in dieser nacht an den
küsten zumindest aber im landesinneren
geht schnell runter unter null grad 0
bis -7 am alpenrand auch noch kälter als
minus zwölf grad und tagsüber wird es im
nebel am kältesten bleiben da haben wir
den dauerfrost teilweise an der donau
sonst sind es drei bis sechs und an den
küsten ostseeküste schleswig holstein
auch sieben oder acht grad da ist es
auch bewölkten frischer westwind direkt
von der nordsee aber im landesinneren
zeigt sich dann die sonne und auch in
der mitte und im süden
es wird überwiegend sonnig nur eben an
der donau im vorhalten gebiet kann sich
der nebel auch längere zeit wieder
halten und es geht eigentlich so ruhig
weiter mal sonnig mal auch wolkig
tagsüber bleibt es meist frostfrei aber
nachts haben wir den frost ich wünschen
noch einen schönen abend und machen
sie's gut